[Music]
hello
the cassandras have been warning of a
crisis for a decade now the specter of
inflation was called first as a risk of
quantitative easing following the
banking crisis back in 2008.
now post pandemic with global debt at
record levels supply bottlenecks around
the world and wholesale gas prices up
tenfold inflation has arrived
many fear interest rate rises to control
inflation will create havoc recession
and hardship across the globe inflation
is already at 10 in brazil and interest
rates there have risen four times in the
past year
will government debt come back to bite
us and the magic money tree turn out not
to be so magical after all could we be
heading for the biggest economic shock
that we've ever known
or are the fears misguided inflation a
temporary blip and government borrowing
and spending not only proven right for
the pandemic but for all future policy
well to debate one of the most important
questions of our era i've got three
fantastic speakers we've got steve hanke
who is one of the world's leading
experts on measuring and stopping
hyperinflation and a former economic
advisor to the reagan administration we
have isabella kaminska who is a colonist
for the financial times and lead editor
of um ft alphaville the ft's market and
finance blog and we have polly toynbee a
british author and journalist who has
written for the guardian for over 20
years and she's authored several books
amongst the most important are the lost
decade 2010 to 2020 and the verdict a
book about the labor years in british
government my name is ron amita and i'll
be your host for tonight
our current levels of inflation putting
us on the brink of economic disaster and
to start us off with that i'm glad to
invite steve hanke steve over to you
well i thank you great to be with you
let me begin by paraphrasing
a dictum of milton friedman
inflation is always and everywhere a
monetary phenomenon
not something caused by temporary
supplies chain disruptions and
accompanying shortages
so
if we
follow that
dictum
we
and we look at inflation we have to go
back to the origin and the origin is
always the money pump
how
how fast is the money supply growing
that will determine
whether we have overall
inflation or not and i'm measuring
inflation
in many countries
around the world and let me just go
through the top eight right now i
measured the inflation rate this morning
now in all those countries
the money supply is growing very rapidly
and that's why you've got so much
inflation
but if you look back historically
let me turn to the world hyperinflations
just to put these numbers into context a
little bit
and a number of years ago i wrote the
chapter in the rootlegged handbook of
major economic events in history
and the chapter on world hyperinflations
contains
all all of the big ones uh except a few
actually
when i wrote this there were 58
hyperinflations today now there are 62.
but hungary
august 1945 was a top one
prices were doubling every 15 hours
zimbabwe
as it turns out november of 2008
prices were doubling every 24.7 hours we
go on down the line in germany which of
course is the most famous hyperinflation
of all times
it comes in number five on on the list
of world hyperinflations
3.7 days in germany so
it was taking about four times longer
to double the prices in germany in 1948
in 1923 than it was in 1945 in hungary
so
it's it's all a money game
where is the money supply going and
that's going to tell you where inflation
is going
thanks very much indeed stephen thank
you for that historical perspective my
day job is as a historian of the chinese
civil war and as you'll know very well
in 1947 to 48 it also had one of the
world's most uh fast-moving inflationary
cycles at that that point so it happens
in many places let me now turn for our
second um
pitch to this question of our current
levels of inflation putting us on the
brink of economic disaster to isabella
kaminska isabella over to you
so
here i'm i'm looking at it from a uk
perspective in this
in a certain way um so we
are sitting here right now and we are
experiencing shortages we've had a
petrol crisis gas prices are uh going up
um we
are facing bare shelves there's an hdb
hgv
driver shortage
and it does feel very much like there is
a perfect storm um in terms of inflation
so um we've had today andrew bailey the
governor of the um
bank of england actually
slightly spooked the markets and um
suggesting that the bank of england is
going to raise rates earlier than
previously expected we are supposedly we
are currently at 0.1
um and the market is now supposedly
looking to price in 0.25
um the big dilemma and big kind of
controversy in markets i guess is
whether or not a interest rate height in
such a environment is going to actually
do any uh any good because if we are
facing a stage stagflationary situation
then there is a big fear that actually
interest rate hikes will simply
impede growth further and make the
problem worse in some ways
but there is another angle
which is being overlooked and that is
the fact that we here we are not just
you know coming out of covid and there
is the great uh debate over whether this
inflation is transitory or not however
many of these bottlenecks will ease
themselves over the year over the next
few months or years um this also
coincides i would argue with the great
sort of esg phenomenon and that is um
the push to sort of starve the fossil
fuel markets of capital um in a in a bid
to kind of push the green agenda forward
um and for years now we've talked about
this in a very positive light um but i
don't think uh it's really been
appreciated to what degree that can be
inflationary in its own right
so
coupling the lockdown uh sort of
transitory issues you have this sort of
push on the green inflation side as as
it's being dubbed now um and we're
seeing the brunt of that in terms of
global energy costs going up this year
uh not least because um there has been
this epic under investment in the energy
sector which is partly cyclical because
obviously covid um amongst other things
so last you know in 2020 we saw march 20
i can't remember
around march 2020 we saw you know oil
prices going almost internet well they
did momentarily go into negative
territory which is not exactly a great
um sort of incentive to invest in the in
the energy sector so there's a cyclical
uh side to that story but on top of that
there is this stranded asset issue which
is that nobody wants to invest because
they fear that um the investments will
never get used and energy investing is
very long-term horizon focus so if
you're not going to get your money back
in say 20 30 years because uh by 2030 20
20 35 you know these assets can't be
utilized to the degree that you might
otherwise want them to so that's that's
where i'm looking at things um that's
the perspective i'm looking at things
from
thanks very much indeed isabella and
plenty there for us to uh to to chew
over um paulie could i now turn to polly
toynbee for the final pitch on this
question are current levels of inflation
putting us on the brink of economic
disaster over to you
i think we have to start from a position
of great humility i think that economics
itself is in a state of great crisis and
we are at the moment finding that we
know less and less and that fewer and
fewer of the old rules seem to hold um i
don't think we know what money is or how
it works and
uh the arrival of crypto currency for
instance has been quite a shock to the
system because it goes against all the
rules does it work does it not work is
it a terrifying dangerous explosive
element in our economies
we have a budget next week and our
chancellor rishi sunak sounds as if he's
going to cleave to all the old economic
conventional possibly untruths um a
fixed idea that um
spending must be covered by by taxation
that you cannot in any one year
um
allow the the deficit to rise we're not
sure that that's true uh or we're
certainly not sure that that medicine
isn't a great deal worse than the
disease it's trying to cure
um
we know the banks create money we've
seen qe has been an extraordinary way of
creating money creating huge amounts of
extra assets for the very wealthy
uh it hasn't been a very satisfactory
way of of dealing with the the the 20
uh
with the 2009 crisis
um
i think it turns out that there is a
kind of magic money tree but nobody
knows how tall it can grow how how how
long it can last
um
what's certain is that as long as stable
countries and we've just had professor
hanky talking about very extreme
collapse societies collapse politics
collapsed economies which i don't think
are very relevant for the relatively
solid economies of our own countries um
we don't you know we can borrow as much
as lenders are willing to lend at the
moment they seem very willing to lend
because they don't know where else to
put their money
so there doesn't seem to be as much
difficulty in um constantly replenishing
the magic money tree i think any idea of
return to that old monetarism
would be a serious a serious error i
think raising interest rates now would
be catastrophic um we know immediately
that how how it's how bad its effects
will be but we don't know what not
raising interest rates might do and
whether how bad its effect might be and
if you know one thing and not the other
then you should use the precautionary
principle and you should not raise
interest rates now it doesn't appear
that wages are driving uh its prices are
raw materials and supplies um not wages
wages are not rising in in written
significantly well maybe for a few hgv
drivers but not for anybody else much
certainly not rising above the rate of
inflation okay
so let's not repeat the big errors that
this country made in 2010 when by uh
imposing strict austerity uh
under george osborne and david cameron
uh turned off the taps it meant that we
were slowest to recover uh from the uh
the great financial crash
uh the great austerity did terrible harm
socially and economically and we have
been behind and we were least prepared
as a result
for the covet crisis we were more
vulnerable than other equivalent
countries
so let's uh hold on to the
doctors
the doctor's principle first do no harm
let's not make things worse by turning
off the taps now
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas